hey you guys I was wondering who
invented Christmas was it a cat must
have been some kind of genius why is
there a dead tree in the living room
did it do something heroic to deserve
all of that shiny stuff and how come you
never give me that many toys have you
seen these shiny boxes and ribbons I
mean come on this holiday has a genius
cats prints all over it
can I touch this no I can't touch this
can I eat this
nope why are you guys grooming each
other under that fake weird plant don't
you know you can groom yourselves at any
time
why do you nap only one time a day and
why for so long don't you know that
there's cats to feed and shiny boxes to
open what kind of mythical beasts need
socks this big is he upset that his feet
are so cold because you took all his
socks if I wear this silly hat can I get
extra dinner I mean seriously
have you tried this Beast sock
let me get this straight I touched the
box yesterday and get put in the laundry
room but now you can just tear them open
and don't you realize the stuff inside
isn't as exciting as all this amazing
paper and ribbon you're just throwing
away I think you're doing Christmas
wrong wait is this my present I guess I
have been a very good girl
well sort of
yep oh crap definitely invented
Christmas Oh gravy
you